[Music]
thank you for joining us today my name
is Emil Kiner I see some people are
filtering in but I'll get started a
product manager on the networking team
and today we'll be talking about DDoS
protection as well as a web application
firewall and we'll talk about a base
journey in and how they've migrated and
evaluated the GCP network and our
abilities to protect from application
attacks I'm joined today by Derek
Chamorro he's a security architect at
eBay and I'm also joined by Terry Barr
you okay
the CTO and founder of relays they'll be
both talking about their solutions and
how they've integrated with with GCP so
today what we're gonna do is I'll go
over and give a kind of a brief
introduction about the Google Network
and talk about its scale and the
infrastructure that supports it and then
we'll dive into a little bit more about
our cloud armor solution which is our
DDoS protection service as well as a web
application firewall we'll go over some
you know customer use cases and most
typical use patterns and after that will
hand it off to Tory to talk about
replays and how they've integrated the
GCP and after that eBay Derek will come
on stage and talk about some penetration
and stress testing that they've done on
the platform to evaluate to migrating
eBay were close to GCP and I hear they
did got some good results we'll have
plenty of time for questions at the end
and when we do we ask that you use the
microphones here in the middle for
questions okay so cloud armors deployed
actually at the edge of Google's global
network it's part of our globe balancing
infrastructure
before I begin I do want to kind of give
an overview of what our network looks
like to give you an idea of the scale
and scope and it goes a long way in
explaining and how we're able to do the
protections that we are able to do so we
actually have 19 regions or data
centers distributed globally you can see
here in blue we also have a few future
ones coming in and those are the the
white dots in addition we have another
134 edge pops or points of presence
these are co-located facilities within
our isp partners data centers and what
that means is we're able to receive
client traffic and put them on the
google network as close as possible to
the clients right so once once a request
is made to a Google IP it gets routed to
the nearest edge pop and then it's on
Google's backbone instead of being
routed through the public Internet
speaking of the backbone we have 13 sub
C cable investments that are either
wholly or partially owned by us right
those are all the the blue lines that
are being strung together on a daily
basis we move the amount of data that we
move across our backbone is orders of
magnitude larger than the the data that
traverses the public Internet what that
means is Google's network capacity is so
large that we are actually able to
effectively absorb and dissipate most of
the most common distributed
denial-of-service attacks without
impacting any availability and
reliability so most of our customers
don't even know that they've been
attacked like on other cloud security is
a shared model on GCP right and when it
comes to network security and security
in general we work to secure our
networks and infrastructure and we
provide all the tools and capabilities
for customers to do the same in their
environments in fact we enable and
encourage customers to follow defense
and depth approach right where you
deploy various security solutions at
various stages of the stack that you can
see here kind of in the way and at every
point in the stack we also have room for
partner solutions to deliver
capabilities that may be more
specialized than we offer natively
now today we'll be talking about cloud
armor up at the top in for application
protection as well as our global load
balancing infrastructure but I will
start off with kind of giving an
overview of of the network security
controls that we have right so we have
three different types of network
security controls that customers often
deploy in unison in red we've got VPC
firewalls these are your traditional
firewalls using layer 3 layer 4
semantics you would use these to define
the perimeter of a V PC north-south as
well as a east-west
but you can even get as granular as per
VM all right so you can use the PC
firewalls to control and define ACLs on
a per VM basis if necessary they have an
analog in blue called B PC service
controls V PC service controls allow you
to define effectively a virtual
perimeter around GCP based services like
managed api's things like Google Cloud
Storage BigTable bigquery the point is
you can use VP service controls to
ensure that only authorized users only
from authorized locations using only
authorized machines can access or
receive the data within those API based
services to mitigate things like data
exfiltration and really just make sure
that only permitted functions are are
executing on your resources and finally
in green we've got cloud armor which is
instrumented and part of our global load
balancing infrastructure and that's able
to filter and drop traffic coming from
the public internet into GCP so as I'll
dive in a little deeper we're able to do
layer 3 through layer 7 filtering and
I'll kind of explain how that works yeah
before doing that you know understanding
how our global load balancing
infrastructure works is is valuable
right so the GCL B is not a DNS based
global load balancer as many of you know
we actually publish in any cast VIP and
this virtual IP is accessible from
anywhere in the world and when a client
coming from California or New York or
Singapore goes and accesses that same IP
the edge pop location nearest to them
will receive that traffic all right and
will then filter that traffic will will
enter that traffic onto the Google's
network where it will be routed to the
nearest region wherever your
applications may be deployed right so if
you only have one your application is
only hosted in one region that's where
the traffic will go but if you have your
applications across different regions
distributed globally then then we will
route the traffic where necessary
so our load balancers are SSL
terminating right and what that means as
customers can do SSL offload you upload
your certificates into into your global
load balancer instance and then we can
decrypt the traffic on the way in and
then we'll re encrypt it on the way back
out to your backends but in that small
sliver of space where it is in plain
text
that's where cloud armor is actually
able to do the inspection and evaluate
and drop the traffic similarly other
points in the stack will filter out and
drop you know bad traffic however that's
defined you know layer 3 layer 4 attacks
malformed packets and things like that
will get scrubbed out at various stages
of the stack all of which happens way
upstream of the of the customer backends
so as I said cloud armor is a part of
our load balancing infrastructure
together with the HTTP load balancer and
cloud armor customers are automatically
protected from the most common types of
distributed denial of service attacks
things like syn floods Act floods DNS
amplifications these are the types of
attacks that hit the news most common
most often these are the ones that have
you know terabit level bandwidth usage
and things like that and all that is
protected and blocked automatically like
I said earlier most of our customers
don't even know that they've been
attacked and we are working on on
exposing that visibility so in the
future you know you will be able to you
know get a report and do sort of
after-action investigation as necessary
cloud armor proper as I said we we are
in the sliver of space where the traffic
is in plain text so we can do full layer
7 inspection we don't look at the body
but we do look at all the request
headers and the cookies so you're
actually able to define Ackles today
with IPS right we were generally
available for a IP allow deny but in the
future it currently in an alpha we've
got geo based access control a full set
of waffe capabilities as well as a
custom rules language to allow you to
define your own rules and all of this
should go without saying but it's good
to repeat it all this is built on top of
infrastructure that we have designed and
built for Google over the past 20 years
to protect against these comet attacks
to make sure that things like search and
ads and Gmail and YouTube all stay up
and available right so it's that same
expertise that we've developed
protecting our own applications that
allows us to go and and enable customers
to leverage that investment
very big numbers there so as I mentioned
cloud armors deployed at the edge of the
network and what that means it's
actually able to enforce the security
policies upstream without consuming your
own compute so cloud armor enables
customers to protect applications from
DDoS right filter incoming requests by
geo as well as most layer 7 parameters
and as a Web Application Firewall we're
also going to ship pre-canned rules to
protect against the web's kind of most
common application attacks so we are
porting over the mod security core rule
set if you're familiar with what that is
and we're starting with sequel injection
cross-site scripting but the plan is to
port over and support the full core rule
set and critically we also have
real-time telemetry for your own
monitoring and security needs I'll show
what that looks like a little bit later
but the point is you've got logs going a
stackdriver and you've also got a
monitoring dashboard that helps you
detect and react when when there is
something to do so as I mentioned the
claudemir security policies are used to
customize access to protected resources
and it could be as flexible and as
uniform or granular as you need so
although the protection happens at the
very edge of the network you can define
the security policy it define access
controls that that could be applied
consistently to all of the our
applications in a single project there's
kind of a one to many relationship
between policy and back-end service or
if the business dictates you can
actually have customized controls where
you would have a security one security
policy per back-end service and all that
matters is you know what what you would
allow or deny into that application once
traffic comes in to a back-end service
that's protected by a security policy
the rules within that policy are
evaluated in priority order right much
like most you know application security
appliances out there although cloud
armor is not an appliance right we we
fall we fall down the list of rules and
order each rule has a match condition
and if traffic matches that match
condition then the action associated
with that rule will be taken the action
can be allowed deny in the future of the
action will be throttle if you need to
do some rate limiting and if none of the
traffic matches if none of the rules hit
then the default action will be taken
and again that could be allowed deny or
throttle in the future and that provides
the ability to to create very flexible
varying Gregg Euler controls one best
practice recommendation of course is
since we terminate evaluation after the
first match it's best to have all of
your deny rules higher priority than
your allow rules right so if you do need
to drop traffic that happens first in
terms of overall features and status so
I've mentioned this as I've talked
before but we do have a rich and
comprehensive feature set some of it is
generally available today we announced
GA back at RSA last month for the
granular policy framework of the overall
distributed denial-of-service protection
the layer 3 layer 4 stuff as well as the
ability to create IP lists to allow or
deny traffic based on IP in those
policies right that's GA as is all of
our telemetry currently in alpha we have
the rest of the laughs slate of features
right that includes geo access controls
that includes our custom rules language
on top of which we've built the mod
security rules right x equal injection
and trusted scripting are up first
shortly thereafter will follow with
things like remote code execution local
file inclusion and remote file inclusion
and then custom rules right so in
addition to us shipping these pre-baked
rules customers will be able to use our
rules language to select on any layer 3
through layer 7 attribute of the of the
traffic in order to to filter out based
on business needs
so now going over some of the most
typical use cases that we've got as I
mentioned before we've got DDoS
protection right that's first and
foremost you get that as soon as you
deploy behind the HTTP load balancer in
cloud armor the idea is we will filter
out and scrub out any bad layer 3 layer
4 traffic to the extent that you're only
serving HTTP or TCP traffic and only
good requests will get to you all right
so this is very common most customers
love this and you know you'll you'll
hear from relays and eBay talking about
their thoughts on this here's an example
of our real-time monitoring dashboard
alright so we provide granular
visibility both you know at a at an
overall level about your incoming
traffic and you know the percentages and
the actual numbers of what's what's
allowed and what's blocked but
critically we also have the ability to
deploy rules in preview mode right so
this is akin to sort of passive rules in
in in older laughs deployments
the idea is you would model the impact
of the rule without it actually having
without it having taking action on your
production traffic right so we log rules
in preview mode they log their action to
stack driver but they don't actually
stop the traffic and then it's up to you
to decide to take an off preview mode so
you're able to monitor the impact of
previewed rules in these management
monitoring dashboards as well you can
visualize it and most importantly you
can set up custom alerting policies
right if using any of the metrics that
are exposed in the monitoring dashboards
you would set up custom alerting
policies to trigger any of your incident
response processes right notify the
right people and then you can go and
take action
one of the most common use cases is
restricting source IPS right many of our
customers have a business need to fill
their filter their traffic through an
upstream proxy right and yet still want
to have their projects in GCP and the
HTTP load balancer will expose a
publicly available IP address so what
they'll do is they'll use cloud armor to
define a default deny all rule right and
then create two higher priority rules
that would allow the source IPS of their
upstream proxy right and perhaps their
own corporate range of IPs and the
effect would be then that only traffic
from the upstream proxy is allowed
through the load balancer to the
back-end services meanwhile anyone else
from the Internet that hits the the
public IP directly would get denied all
right that's only if you need to force
traffic to come through an upstream
proxy and and the final use case I want
to talk about today is the idea of
downstream detection and upstream
enforcement right so the the way that
this generally works is customers will
deploy some basic cloud armor security
policies all right and they'll have
their applications within GCP as
back-end services and they also have
their own sort of custom monitoring
custom monitoring solutions right there
they're doing monitoring and analytics
looking at the application logs but
they're also bringing in data from a lot
of other sources like oh there we go
they're bringing data from other sources
maybe the load balancer logs maybe you
know anything else going to their own
Sox you know any events go into their
sims things like that on top of that
they'll have threat or fraud detection
algorithms running or abuse detection
you know and any number of things that
they'll go identify something that's bad
based on you know things they're unique
to their applications taking you know
all the context necessary and then
they'll define a signature and then push
that signature as a cloud armor rule
upstream right the idea is once you've
decided that some set of traffic is bad
you can go and enforce that upstream
cloud armor and that you would have near
real-time propagation you know measured
in minutes to globally to globally
enforce these security policies with
that I'd like to hand it off to to Tory
invite him back on stage to talk about
replays and and their integration with
that with GCP yeah give a hand to a meal
for the grit into the presentation about
cloud armor so before diving into my
slides I'd like to take this opportunity
to thank you both the team at Google and
at eBay for the these for your trust
first of all for your trusted for this
great amazing journey we did together
in the last several months so replays is
a comprehensive security platform or to
be more precise comprehensive
application security platform employed
in the cloud we're about to explore
replays the comprehensive of the
features of free blaze as well as our
relays integrated into GCP leverages GCP
products and platforms cloud arm already
mentioned but also a few other products
such as cloud security command center
Vickery and machine learning relays is a
cloud native solution that provides you
with nearly everything you need to
control and command your application
when we're looking at today's threat
Maps threats risk map we think it will
be wise to divide divided into four
different pillars DDoS well-known common
on a daily basis
but management which is basically a
subset of DDoS or
sure some similarities with DDoS in
terms of automated traffic runs across a
large network but instead of flooding
your network flooding your resources
with incoming traffic by detection
solution now but management solution
will protect your platform from attack
status' account takeover brute-force
login even credit card fraud and simple
scraping data scraping if your business
is your data and vice versa scraping is
the issue you have to deal with
literally every minute the next is where
Application Firewall while DDoS and
Batman has been focusing on traffic
behaviors in patterns within atrophic
where placated firewall focuses on the
data the actual data submitted over to
the server does the data contains any
malicious vectors XSS sequel injections
we must file inclusions etc and last but
not least especially nowadays API
security and one might think what makes
the API security a special case while it
probably can be described as you adjust
another web application platform which
is simple HTTP requests back and forth
reading data and responding to the
clients however
today's API or is it called modern api's
is while originally were designed to
enable computers service communicate
with each other
today's API by design serving humans and
vas and machines at the same time if you
have an API and you built your web
application with angular or react or any
other framework so you're you're the
user interface the interacting within
the browser or within a mobile device
actually using API underneath and the
very same API will be used when you will
release your mobile native application
and at the same time your clients are
affiliates will use the same set of API
to communicate and to transfer data
between their service in yours so which
really is one of the one of the key
strengths of free blaze is enabling you
in in most cases automatically profile
each in every case and assigned the
designated policy optimized for each
case so human a human access API will be
enforcing and monitoring the human
behavior along the line while machines
are be the V API server the server API
will will enjoy and will run under
different completely different policy
also by definition the fact API is all
about transmitting data back and forth
API is eventually each operation put
some data put some string of byes either
in a database on the hard drive and that
suggests direct access to a database
somehow and therefore security became
much more critical and last but from the
service we took from our clients as well
as from you know were analysts are
actually reporting
the greatest challenge with API today is
where are they so it used to be a flash
API or API subdomain to run your API but
today's within organizations api's are
becoming available publicly available on
a daily basis literally every cloud
function you put out every micro service
your release or you consume and utilize
there's actually an API so for the
system administrator for the security
engineer with an organization there is
no way they actually know unfamiliar
with the location and purpose of each
and every API because developers simply
releasing them on a daily basis so let's
talk about the setup of relays and its
relations relationship with the cloth
armor and other cloud security product
so in a typical DCP product you will
have an email is actually coverage some
of it so you will have a global city on
your phone the global CDN will be
working in conjunction with a global
load balancer and in DCPS in cloud are
more so sitting will be handling and
deliver content delivery in a most
efficient way load balancer will handle
everything related to SSL termination
and ensuring high availability and clog
arm or is processing a hailing the
security so you have those three
products in platforms actually becoming
your front shield and your front shield
for your front and foyer for your global
public funding for your traffic the
replays sighs right next to it so
instead of all advanced are
communicating with your scale group with
your reference directly your low the low
gossip we communicate with relays these
are the relays enforces the DDoS block
all the bus
operates with its web application
firewall and provides the API security
[Applause]
along we what Reba's does in real time
protecting blocking dropping or letting
in riblets pushes all the data to
bigquery it's not real time it's about
10 seconds 10 to 12 seconds delay but
it's nearly real-time now this is where
all the fun stuff are happening because
bigquery blaze is being continuously
analyzed used to analyze the data in
every incoming request and every every
session being analyzed continuously and
as we detect attacks or misbehave from a
user from a session attacks of which you
cannot block based upon a given request
rather you need some track record you
need to see a pattern as we detect I saw
an attack source
we blaze proxies immediately get updated
as well as clouds are more get updated
immediately so there's immediate action
taking taking place as attacks is attack
attack so detected the set up the way we
set it up NLB enable enabled us to
provide you the users with four features
or some a call it principles which we
believe are key requirements in every
security solution the one is absolute
visibility that is a given you cannot
protect against something you're not
seeing in a web a web scale when you
process millions or billions of requests
a day you have to have the ability to
facility the the tools to analyze and
get to each and every record and track
each and every session
but relays we do more than just data
analysis in real-time the second
principle is the immediate action as I
mentioned action taken in every request
further process or drop immediately we
detect the source of the attack object
immediately proxies after Tomatoes
declared or more not only that we also
have we integrated with Google other sim
products called constitutive command
center so also we push alerts and we
push all the events to your commensal so
you can get in one screen you get all
the recent attacks and if event is
taking place you will you'll be able to
take action immediately straight from
the portal this the third feature is
recommendation we help you we help do
the thinking for you it's really hard to
keep in mind all the areas all the
policies required all the changes
between your application as I'll show
you some replays provides a
recommendation where security policy
might be better off fine-tune restricted
access API discovery as we as I
explained nobody knows who they were the
API is we believe given the capacity and
availability of bigquery everyday we
analyzed the entire traffic and we spot
errors which we detected API activity
and we say ok here's an API section
within your application it is not
profiled here as an FBI would you like
to in one click set it as API so it will
enjoy all the capabilities of API
securing
and last is our biometric behavioral
analysis so this is a capability which
in a recent month became the tool
[Applause]
dee-dee-dee tool that we actually
fighting and detecting the most
sophisticated buzz and and the biometric
I will just will explain how it works so
in addition to the session graph that we
hold in process in Robles per user for
each user
there is another graph which we maintain
and that is the human interaction the
human presence along the session so as
applications we protected by blades
every click and every keyword that every
every click on the keyboard every
tapping scrolling every event that
happens on the client side is monitored
and reported the relays and analyzing
the query so when we look at the data
when we look at where we inspect and
analyze the session and each and every
session get analyzed not only that we
have all the data and all the
transactions performed by this session
we also have was there a human at all do
we actually are we dealing with a human
or just emulated or headless browser or
any type of sophisticated but attacks
and that wouldn't be possible without
the bigquery because given we're
processing billions literally billions
of billions of requests a day big fir
gives us the ability to add on top of it
several other billions of mouse clicks
and keyboards and yet provides you as a
user in our platforms our systems our
immediate analysis and immediate
information about for each and every
session when we talk about visibility if
I may take a few more seconds to expand
the visibility of free blaze so in
addition to the fact that every request
every header every cookie every
authentication action every API call is
report is stored in replays in analyzing
relays we enrich every every quest with
metadata which gives us a better
profiling of each and every session for
instance every question relays is marked
is it a human or it is browser or a lot
is this session operating within the Tor
network or beyond proxy or behind a VPN
is it a server VPS on a cloud somewhere
a data center or is it a domestic office
link connection and those profiles
absolute visibility means all this data
is always available to make decision to
take action when needed another case
which bigquery another case which
require become critical for us is about
detecting a brute-force attacks such as
logins or account takeover for instance
anybody recognize this what this is so
this is one of the ephah of the things
we found when working with Derek and his
team it's basically you probably if you
know with Gmail your mailbox on the left
side to the add sign you can spell it
out wherever you want with any number of
dots at any position it will always be
the same inbox so if you have a
mechanism that says validate your
account by sending you an email
and your Lincoln arm you go your Lincoln
a click you click on the link and that's
all your account is validated what we
have found in this case this particular
case in thousands of cases like this we
found six hundred ninety seven different
variations of this email as you saw now
those cases we found them by mistake
with we have we had not planned to go
and seek for this particular attack but
given the machine learning and the
analysis run on bigquery continuously
the algorithm detected too much of a
similarity between hundreds of hundreds
of accounts a take a look at this we
spot something
okay so relays has more features than
that but time doesn't allow us to do so
and at this case I will handle it over
to Derek so you can share with us his
experience with relays and cloud armor
Thank You Zuri so first I want to thank
our legal team for allowing me to talk
about this because in most cases we're
not allowed to so some of you might be
wondering why I'm up here you know given
the nature of eBay we kind of build
their own servers and we you know put
them all around our global data centers
but like most of you I'd like to be
prepared as a security professional to
I'm you know extremely paranoid about
whatever the next big attack is and when
I think about you know some of our
brands potentially going into an area
that we don't own and if we don't have a
proper strategy in place then that
potentially is a threat vector for us so
part of this use case was determined how
could we replicate our existing known
you know perimeter security controls
into an environment that essentially we
don't know so some of you might think of
no eBay as being just a calm you know
and it's an online marketplace with over
175 million users with over 1.1 billion
live listings at any time but I like to
think of eBay is kind of like the roof
of a house and under that roof we have
many brands that fit our marketplace
strategy you know whether it be stuff up
which is the world's largest online
ticket marketplace or some a lot of our
other
Rand's and help people around the world
find what they're looking for in their
local communities so what do they all
share in common well we have the
security train we cheat them all equally
and we want to ensure that we're
technique not only their brand image but
their reputation so some of the goals
that we had with this is we wanted to
first experiment with you know how we
could you know extend this perimeter
protection strategy no matter where our
data could live second we wanted to kind
of preserve the same level of visibility
that we currently have with an armed
premise systems ideally we want to be
able to correlate that data with our
on-premise systems with whatever we were
able to achieve in an environment that
we didn't listen to we didn't element in
second and third we just wanted to see
if we could break anything I mean that
the inner hacker and all of us we want
to see where we could induce some kind
of failure whether it be within
something we found within Google or
something we found within relays or
something we found within the systems we
provisioned and on a side note when we
asked our customer engineer just said
hey listen we want to DDoS Google I
expected some kind of delay and I was
actually really surprised when he said
yeah let's do it so you know it made me
pretty happy about that so a lot of you
who have developed a DDoS security
program may be familiar with this but
this is you know part of the approach of
having a successful defensive strategies
to pick create tooling for common DDoS
threat vectors so we put it across three
pillars anomaly detection visibility and
forensics and attack mitigation and in
most cases all these work together to to
mitigate attacks so you might have a
small attack that sneaks under
configured threshold so to mitigate that
potential impact you know the you would
first look at some kind of anomaly
detection alert and would this alert you
would use your existing visibility and
forensics tools to determine whether or
not the attack was real and then looking
for ways to be able to block the attack
and then you would use your attack
mitigation tools to to implement some
kind of filter review filter that out so
with this in mind we built a set of
requirements that could mirror the
existing tooling that we had on-premise
and do kind of like a feature parity
comparison with existing controls
available through Google as well as
through their trusted partners
so we decided to build a test site and
well test setup wasn't a replica of what
our traditional sites would look like we
wanted to build a project that would
represent all aspects of what we want to
accomplish from this test and we
discussed actually building a mirror
sight but we realized we probably blow
through our security budget for the
entire year so this is an example of
what we had and first we wanted to build
something was fully automated if we
encounter any failure we want to just be
able to destroy it and rebuild it as it
is so it kind of shows a reflection of
the attack traffic that we would expect
in so first on the right-hand side
we before we engage with any other third
parties we decided to build some attack
VMs and kind of create like this hairpin
traffic that would come into the
internet and it first hit the Google
front end so we automatically knew that
we had your art l3 and l4 protection
that was managed by Google so once it
hit that layer after that it hit the
specific test project where we parked a
domain we didn't want to have anything
to do with eBay we just wanted to be
something separate that way you know we
didn't have any liability if anything
ever happened to us but what it was was
it was a cloud DNS managed own
externally we had a static IP assigned
to the load balance bit and attached to
less encrypted managed certificate with
it that automatically rotated and then
it did our SSL offloading for us so the
next top would then be the relays proxy
tier
so this replays proxy tier was managed
instance group which use an instance
template of a managed image through
replays it was using n1 standard 16
instance types which is 16 B CPUs and 60
gigs of ram each and it auto scaled
based off of demand so in reality what
for the test we just kept two instances
running at all times and during the test
it would auto scale based off of
specific metrics we had provision for it
and then we had the bigquery the logs go
to bigquery so as a structured data set
that was I am controlled we had access
to him nobody else did and that was part
of the reasons why we wanted to do this
experiment we wanted to maintain some
kind of control of the data that we were
actually create
from there it would forward it to a
nother cloud DNS managed on that was
considered internal and then it sent it
to this specific tier of VM to be
provisioned
these are vulnerable docker instances
that we that we created we a lot of the
there were susceptible things like OS
top-ten attacks the idea is that we
wanted to keep them to the point where
we could break them so if anything
penetrated here we wanted to see monitor
this is the specific tier and see if see
if anything failed within the upper part
of the stack so we partnered up with a
third-party DDoS company specialized and
kind of test-driving what your security
controls are your d/deaf mitigation
solutions are to simulate the true scale
of a distributed attack and we wanted to
focus on specific DDoS types we're
considered common types from layer 3 to
layer 7 for our test cycle so the layer
3 layer 4 attacks listed were more
focused on mega megabits per second as
an example like a UDP flood which uses
UDP Datagram containing IP packets to
flood random ports on a target network
or more the layer 7 attacks one more
connection focused per connection per
second focused like HTTP flood which is
an attack that uses a large number of
HTTP GET or post requests to target an
application or web server so the
sequence of events was the vendor
initiating each attack individually
during each attack we search for impacts
to availability through a series of
scripted curl requests and web page
reloads and then monitor the performance
on the VMS and then following each
attack we cleared out any dynamic IP
blacklists before the next attack start
started so here the results of the test
as follows so a pass means good in our
case so no visible impact to any of the
back-end service VMs and a fail would
mean there was visible impact that back
in service VM so as expected all layer 3
attacks were mitigated at the dual front
end via cloud armor any of the non TCP
traffic was discarded by a gules
distributed firewall and this left
literally only the TCP connection floods
and he's to be flag attacks that could
reach the for an end bit
so here are some of our findings and
this is kind of like the feedback mind
you when we did this test we've this
late last year we worked really well
with Google to say hey listen this is
some of what we found and some of the
product that you see today and that was
actually released at RSA is from some of
the feedback that we were able to give
them to make the product you know a lot
more resilient so at the time you know
all the attacks were silently dropped so
we really didn't get any visibility into
that we didn't really have a like the
rich logs that we want to see ideally
you want to be able to correlate that
across all your properties so you
weren't able to do things like short
term log analysis or short search and
through our threat analysis or long-term
threat analysis and that's kind of tack
kind of some of the feedback we gave we
wanted to see comes fun with some kind
of summary logs so that we could be
aware of any anomalous activity was
happening in Google and at the same time
so we could start correlate that and
training that across all of our
properties so as you can see all the
layer seven attacks were mitigated
within replays either through dynamic
rule or BOTS challenges and following
each tests we needed to clear the
dynamic IP blacklists so that the next
at a test is successful iran and from a
visibly perspective again some of the
things that we encounter is that some of
the load balance logs were provided some
rudimentary access logs and not a form
that was easy analyzed and by the time
they only contained IP blacklists
logging from the relays perspective you
know although all the data was through
bigquery some of the can table ization
were difficult to pivot we gave that
feedback to replays and they made them a
lot better and again since everything is
logged to bigquery leak you can kind of
build your own analysis tools if you
want to but for visibility these are
enabled offenses that we had so the
global ACL is a dynamic is a network
based ACL it does things like IP
blocking ASM blocking or via country the
the two that we primarily use with the
global DRX X deny which is a dynamic IP
blacklists
and the deny bot deny anonymous proxies
and denied or self explanatory those
lists are automatically updated for us
but a deny bot is interesting because a
lot of vendors what they normally do is
just you their response is just injected
JavaScript
we foundry blazing to be a lot more
intelligent where it takes a lot of
human detection components in order be
able to check that it's actually a bot
so some of the techniques were and by
environment validation and proof of
proof of work human behavior interaction
which is a little bit like mouse clicks
moves and scrolls develop data
connection and then we had a default
eBay West policy which is where we
whitelisted HTTP methods getting post
and denying all others that way we could
allow certain arguments in while denying
everything else so what you see here are
the relays traffic graphs and this is
the graph of the scripted attack test
before after enduring on the y-axis you
see it represents the connections per
second while the bottom shows a time
range and so this is a scripted HTTP
based web flood and so you can see that
replay starts by challenging each
request and asking the bot to request
the same page
since the bot never request the same
page its request has not not passed
through and these bots get caught by the
web page dynamic rules and then our
temporary blacklisted and again you can
kind of see the trending from the
bandwidth as well so I start sending
challenges the bandwidth increase and as
soon as the as soon as the bots are
moved to the dynamic blacklist the
bandwidth drops and as a meal mentioned
previously these dynamic blasts can be
configured to auto s ability to cloud
armor and again this is the simulated
browser attack and we had some
connection strangers during the test but
as with the scripted attacks you can see
that the same thing went out the
challenges went out and as soon as as
soon as challenging the response several
times the bots got moved into a dynamic
blacklist and again the same with each
band with a Woody to re-raise proxy so
the break for us it would pass
claudemir provides scaled out defenses
against volumetric DDoS attacks and
Google's reputation precedes proceed
itself with mitigating these type
attacks there was a few different the
blips that we found is that some of the
telemetry and but given the feedback we
were able to give we see that in the
product that is today and again with
revelations bought detection and dynamic
rules
it was amazing at being able to stop a
lot of the layer seven attacks that that
we encountered at the same time the VIP
room the visibility perspective we were
actually able to get a lot of salami
tree that we wanted so overall boob
cloud armor replays were sound solution
tree DDoS attacks of all kinds that's
that
also we have there's a survey on your
app so if you could please take some
time to get some feedback and thank you
[Applause]
[Music]